what's up everyone thanks for checking
out this week in cloud where we serve
you the lowest latency news navigating
the cloud can be tricky so we want to
make sure you have all the tools you
need to succeed first up we're hosting
an instructor-led training session to
help you get the fundamentals together
this class will give you an overview of
some of the most popular google cloud
solutions through presentations demos
and hands-on labs come learn with us of
course if you're not in the area or you
can't make it you can also check out the
fundamentals or other courses on
Coursera this is a great tool for
self-paced learning and you still get to
try running the code with hands-on
tutorials there are tons of courses that
can help you learn and get certified so
find the right content for you now once
you know the fundamentals you'll
probably want to try running some jobs
in the cloud Google Cloud Composer is a
managed version of Apache airflow that
automatically scales to run your
workflows we've just launched a solution
article to help you get a better
understanding run a sample workflow that
backs up virtual machines and it gets
you ready to start customizing your own
jobs try it out for yourself and see
what you can build now again if what
you're trying to build needs security
and spoiler alert it probably does and
you want to manage the cryptographic
keys yourself there are also some new
client libraries and code samples for
you to get started from the cloud key
management service gives you control of
your encryption and integrates into our
cloud identity suite letting you more
easily build secure applications check
out the new samples and use the new
client libraries to secure your apps and
if your apps use speech to text or text
to speech we're excited to share that
we've rolled out some great updates more
features more voices more languages
better accuracy and lower prices if
you've been interested in trying these
out there's no better time than now
so check out how we've made our models
better then try them out for yourself
and don't forget the first 60 minutes of
audio you process every month with
speech text is free if you want to read
more about these announcements or see a
full list check out the link have any
thoughts or ideas leave us a comment or
tweet us we'll see you in the cloud